[Music]
hey
everyone welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing none other than popular
hufflepuff student
cedric diggory more specifically however
we're going to be discussing his
untimely death
at the hands of wormtail aka peter
pettigrew
during the penultimate moments of the
goblet of fire
now whether you're a film goer or a book
reader the untimely death of cedric
diggory
was no doubt impactful it happened
during the third
challenge of the triwizard tournament
just after harry and cedric
simultaneously clutched the tri-wizard
cup unbeknown to them
however the triwizard cup was actually a
portkey
a portkey that sent them straight to
wormtail voldemort
and little hangleton graveyard it was
here that cedric lived out his final
moments
ultimately reaching his fate the hands
of peter pettigrew and his killing curse
this is outlined in chapter 32 of the
goblet of fire
flesh blood and bone harry felt his feet
slammed to the ground
his injured leg gave way and he fell
forward his hand
let go of the tri-wizard cup at last he
raised his head
where are we he said cedric shook his
head
he got up pulled harry to his feet and
they looked around
they had left the hogwarts grounds
completely they had obviously traveled
miles
perhaps hundreds of miles for even the
mountains surrounding the castle were
gone
they were standing inside a dark and
overgrown graveyard
the black outline of a small church was
visible beyond a large u-tree to their
right
they pulled out their ones harry kept
looking around him
he had yet again the strange feeling
that they were being watched
someone's coming he said suddenly
squinting tensely through the darkness
they watched the figure drawing nearer
walking steadily toward them between the
graves
harry lowered his one slightly and
glanced sideways at cedric
cedric shot him a quizzical look they
both turned back to watch the
approaching figure
it stopped beside a towering marble
headstone
only six feet from them for a second
harry and cedric and the short figure
simply looked at one another and then
without warning
harry's scar exploded with pain it was
agony
such as he had never felt in all his
life his wand slipped from his fingers
as he put his hands over his face his
knees buckled
he was on the ground and he could see
nothing at all his head
was about to split open from far away
above his head
he heard a high cold voice say kill
the spare a swishing noise and a second
voice
which screeched the words to the knight
avada kedavra
a blast of green light blazed through
harry's eyelids and he heard something
heavy
fall to the ground beside him the pain
in his scar reached such a pitch that he
wretched
and then it diminished terrified of what
he was about to see
he opened his stinging eyes cedric was
lying spread eagle on the ground beside
him
he was dead for a second that contained
an eternity
harry stared into cedric's face at his
open grey eyes
blank and expressionless as the windows
of a deserted house
and his half-open mouth which looked
slightly surprised
and that was the last time we ever saw
cedric alive the popular hufflepuff
student
and promising young wizard before we go
any further
i want to make one thing clear this what
if is not
fueled by the circumstances of the
cursed child
if you didn't know already the cedric
diggory from the cursed child
turns evil however the rationale behind
cedric changing allegiances
in that timeline is primarily driven by
the fact that he was embarrassed
by his extremely unfortunate
circumstances and that they somehow
tarnished his reputation
however to me this doesn't mesh well
with cedric's character
sure cedric had a certain amount of
pride and honor pertaining to his
magical ability and
status at hogwarts i get it but the
notion that he would somehow become a
pure evil
just because he inaccurately determined
that his status was now lost
makes no sense how could only
embarrassment push an otherwise
level-headed man
to madness furthermore it's ridiculous
to assume
that this same embarrassment would push
cedric to seek vengeance for his
non-existent humiliation to add to this
the rationale behind cedric surviving in
the cursed child
comes down to harry's son albus and
draco's son scorpius
messing with a time turner with the time
turner they travel decades back in time
and save his life given the delicate
nature of the fabric of time
not a fan of this answer however with
that said i still want to explore a
what if pertaining to cedric surviving
i'm just going to approach it in a very
different way
first let's start with a brief recap on
who cedric
is cedric diggory was a british pure
blood wizard
born in the year 1977 he began studying
at hogwarts in the year 1989
two years before harry potter and the
trio cedric was a talented wizard
and was sorted into hufflepuff house in
his formative year at hogwarts
cedric had a reputation of being a bit
of a pretty boy but was well liked by
the student body
eventually becoming prefect for
hufflepuff house and captain of the
hufflepuff quidditch team
cedric notably competed against harry in
the triwizard tournament
and it was here that cedric was
tragically killed but
was he really killed first off i'm going
to discuss a what-if scenario
that addresses his possible survival we
know that peter pettigrew was the one to
fire the fatal killing curse at cedric
and to any casual observer cedric was
quite evidently dead
harry saw cedric's grey blank
expressionless eyes first hand
and when he finally escaped the
graveyard he brought cedric's motionless
body back with him
this meant that many others saw cedric's
lifeless body
confirming that his death had in fact
occurred however
what if peter pettigrew's evada cadaver
wasn't actually powerful enough to kill
cedric
in the goblet of fire we're taught that
the unforgivable curses
crucio imperio and most importantly
avada kadavra
require a lot of powerful magic to be
successfully cast
avada kedavra is a curse that needs a
powerful bit of magic behind it
you could all get your ones out and
point them at me and say the words
and i doubt i'd get so much as a
nosebleed so in this what-if scenario
i want to explore the possibility that
peter pettigrew's killing curse
wasn't actually powerful enough to
properly kill cedric
it only got him most of the way at this
stage voldemort hadn't yet returned to
his proper form
and there was a lot of pressure on
pettigrew to make sure that everything
went according to plan
because of this pressure and because
pettigrew had been left to his own
devices
for so many years he simply lacked the
power concentration
necessary to properly execute the curse
this meant that after cedric diggory was
buried on a beautiful hill
he actually woke up after waking up
cedric needed answers
and the first person to realize that
cedric had been reawakened
was voldemort who used legilimensi to
invade his mind
while exploring his mind voldemort saw a
lot of confusion
with an element of underlying anger
anger that he wanted to
capitalize on infiltrating his thoughts
voldemort eventually convinces cedric to
meet with him
when they meet voldemort has already
sussed him up and knows exactly how to
trigger his emotions
cho chang he uses the gilamenti to show
cedric harry with cho
and while at first cedric ignored it
he's eventually pushed to his absolute
limit
when voldemort shows harry kissing cho
he convinces cedric that it was harry's
plan
all along to bring him to the graveyard
and that he used him
always in pursuit of cedric's love
interest cho
this drives cedric to insanity but
voldemort didn't stop there
he explained to him that everyone
thought that he was dead and that no one
would accept him anymore
he also explained that no one would ever
believe his side of the story
that the boy who lived would commit such
atrocities
this turns cedric to the dark side and
becomes just
another unnamed death eater from here
cedric actively participates in the
wizarding war
hiding under his death eater mask out of
shame
however when the fall of voldemort
becomes apparent cedric retreats and
travels far away
from here cedric vows to destroy harry
potter
in exactly the same way that voldemort
wanted to destroy him
he isolates himself from the rest of the
wizarding world and begins to hone
his already advanced magical abilities
effectively becoming the next big threat
after voldemort and that's it for this
what if
i hope you enjoyed it just having a bit
of fun if you enjoy the content please
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
we'll celebrate a boy who was kind and
honest and brave and true
right to the very end
you